in this episode we're going to implement
lazy loading with angular for lazy
loading is a technique that allows you
to render components asynchronously when
a certain route is activated this can
help with the initial loading
performance of an angular app let's get
started by building a new app from
scratch with the angular CLI make sure
to pass the routing flag so angular
builds a default router for us let's
start in the app component HTML and just
set a router link going to the lazy
loaded component which in this case will
be activated on lazy slash load me the
next step is to build the lazy loaded
module as well as its components when
building the lazy module we want to pass
the flat flag to keep it in the root
directory then for each component we can
pass the module flag followed by lazy
that will automatically assign these
components to the lazy module inside the
module itself we're going to import the
route module then define an array of
routes in this case we just have one
route the points to load me that
imperatively loads the lazy parent
component when inputting the router
module we use the for child function and
we pass it the routes array that we just
create there's nothing special about the
parent component it's all boilerplate
code and it just loops over the child
component the final step is to point the
app router to this new module in the
route definitions we create a new route
whose path is lazy then use the load
children property to point to that
module so we point to the file path for
the module and then use a hash followed
by the actual class of the module itself
the end result is the lazy module is
only loaded when this route is activated
let's make sure it's working in the
browser open Chrome developer tools and
then go to the network tab when we
activate the route we should see that
components rendered as well as a chunk
J's file rendered in the network tab
if we take a closer look we can see it's
just a bunch of web pack JavaScript code
towing angular how to load these
components that's it for this episode if
you found the video helpful please like
and subscribe and if you want to support
the channel consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase comm for
just a few bucks a month you'll get
access to exclusive content as well as
free one on one project and full team
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]